brought to you by total war warhammer
colossal battles addictive empire
building hundreds of hours of strategic
gameplay order now and get chaos
warriors free hey guys it is Thursday
the 27th of May my name is Jess and
you're watching games what news the
latest issue of edge magazine has
revealed some brand new details about
the Last Guardian firstly and clearly
most importantly your enormous bird dog
pal trico can shoot lightning from its
tail GamesRadar has reported try ko's
ability is linked to a mirror picked up
by the boy which is wielded like a
shield point the shield in a direction
and the creature will fire a devastating
bolt of red electricity game director
for me to aveda who said that making use
of chacas power will be very important
adding that they gave tracker the
ability to help players understand the
creatures ferocity he said I believe
things are more attractive when there's
a bit of oddness to them rather than
something being normal and appearing to
be generally acceptable the same thing
can be said about triose appearance the
edge article added that treecko's eyes
will change color depending on its mood
which is perfectly adorable and striker
feathers to stand on edge when it's
angry in very awkward news the head of
my team number 9 developer inti creates
has called the game's new trailer
horrible sakuya izu tweeted out his
disdain to what we can assume is deep
silver saying what the hell were they
thinking making a crappy TV like this
unforgivable the trailer has garnered a
lot of criticism for a massively
derisive comment about anime fans when
the narrator says the player can make
the bad guys cry like an anime fan on
prom night also of concern is the game's
visual fidelity which fans say has
gotten worse since the game's prototype
phase and for eats fire effects that
look a hell of a lot like slices of
pepperoni pizza cramped together so much
so that sonic the hedgehog's official
twitter account has also gotten in on
the
an anonymous insider has told polygon
that the rumored upgraded Xbox one is
going to be faster than the ps4 and to
the upgraded ps1 neo codenamed Scorpio
the next xbox one will allegedly run at
six teraflops which would make it four
times as fast as the standard xbox one
and three times faster than the current
ps4 previous reports have suggested that
the upgraded ps4 neo will run at just
overclocked went one teraflop it's
expected that the xbox one Scorpio will
ship by the end of 2017 the polygon
report also claimed that the new system
will have universal compatibility which
will enable support for all previously
released xbox one games Microsoft are
set to announce a whole bunch of things
during their e3 press conference which
takes place at 9am on jun 13 let me know
down in my comment box if you're keen
for an xbox one upgrade or not and why
you should head to games but we've got
stories on both Recon wildlands and
confronts game breaking bugs that is
everything a happy today we do join the
same time tomorrow for the biggest
stories of the entire week I'll see you
then